[Music]
always going on YouTube
now going to the gym I've noticed
something that has been a little bit
hard to get over see I don't really live
at the gym so I'm not sure if this is
just me or is David so just being a
[ __ ] now when it comes to gym
activities usually about 98% of the time
I'm a [ __ ] that's right I said it
I'm gonna [ __ ] at least I'm real with
myself I meant doing at the gym that you
hear screaming when he's curling like 15
pound dumbbells and [ __ ] [ __ ] is that
a pterodactyl but what I really want to
ask is how come nobody really wipes up
after their sweat and I don't want to
hear excuses and [ __ ] like well let a
gym you supposed to sweat fat ass
hey no [ __ ] [ __ ] I know you're
supposed to swing the puck to a fat man
about sweating I know more than you you
sweat when you work out great
that's what's supposed to happen I sweat
for no [ __ ] reason look right out
loud I sweat when I [ __ ] what oh god
damn it
real talk I once watched a live dance
competition I was sweating from watching
them dance
I was so sweaty then after the show was
over everybody came up to me and told me
I did a great job on the show
what hey nice sweat rate great
performance yeah [ __ ] I wasn't dancing
did a round of applause then tired me
out but what you see that you have left
a pool of your liquid on a community
machine you realize that somebody gotta
suck this [ __ ] up I don't want to sweat
on me I don't know you I don't know
where you been you could be a dude nasty
ass freak swimming in Dookie 24/7 donkey
month you could be the Dookie monster
that's the Ripley then the real thing is
Dookie monster real thing Oh after you
drench the bench wipe up and clean up
after yourself and don't get mad when
other people ask you to do it
let's [ __ ] common sense let me ask
you something you want your ass after
you [ __ ] that's right I bet you do and
if you don't that's probably why your
butthole is itching all the time goddamn
it but yes funny fat fit fam thanks to
you guys and your support I finally got
to cut my [ __ ] hair thank God now as
you can tell even with the 20 pounds
that I lost I still got a long ways to
go
not so much it turns up a weight goal
but more in Fitness I I still don't feel
like I'm at a hundred percent and I
still have a lot more than I want out of
this so now that I've reached my first
ball I have another one that's going to
come up that I will share with you on
the next video but today let's talk
about one of the workouts
worked for me that I love now before we
start this I'm going to let you guys
know right now obviously I am NOT a
personal trainer and this is your stuff
that works for me now in terms of form
and technique do not ask me I learned
from somebody else who knew what they
were doing so I think you should go and
go ahead and ask other people who are
more experienced not me so one of my
favorite workouts that I was doing while
losing this weight was squats why squats
us because your legs are such a huge
part of your body and a huge muscle
group that it burns a lot of calories
and what you guys also forget those
people who only get buff up top and then
when you tap them on the shoulder dishes
that your legs are very important and
doing squats is such a great workout why
because it works on your quads it can
work on your calves if you do cath list
with the squats it'll work on your
glutes and then on top of that it also
works your core because as you have the
weight on your back you tighten that
[ __ ] up burns a lot of [ __ ] calories
yes so for those you out there that are
neglecting your lower body for shade and
don't say [ __ ] like well I don't want to
get too muscular what happened listen
here [ __ ] if it was that easy to get
buff everybody would do it but you got
to start somewhere so the workout for
this week is squats and if you do not
know how to do it don't just go in and
just start trying to happen know get
trained as somebody who knows what
they're doing
and somebody who's reputable and have
them teach you if you guys do want to
know who's really good at this stuff is
bart quan go ahead and check out his
fitness channel and he can help you out
but yes body fat fit fam remember light
is always what you make it but it's up
to you to take what you deserve
let's go for broke yes you too funny fat
bin is back thank you guys once again
for your support and it's really the
only reason why I got to here was well
actually half the reason was because of
you guys you guys were there for me so
remember what do you guys do your funny
fat fit and you're doing your private
stuff do it with me go on Instagram
upload those pictures and a hashtag
funny fat fit and when you do hashtag
funny fat dick when you're working out
imma be there and comment and thumbs up
your pictures and let you know that my
with you every step of the way I know it
seems that I'm not but I can't go
through life you know hundreds and
thousands of post and be like leave you
guys personal message but I will like it
and trust me I am watching it so
remember hashtag funny fat they put up
videos pictures whatever and if you can
do your own set of videos and then tweet
the videos at me so I can watch your
progress and give you guys words of
encouragement let's do this
and another thing that I'm doing right
now I'm getting personally trained
that's right this is something that I
haven't done I'm getting personally
trained by Khalif Boyd if you don't know
who Khaliq Boyd is he's been in a lot of
my videos such as let me touch your fro
but he also has his own fitness thing so
if you guys want to get personally
trained for him for a great deal and a
great price go to cleef Boyd hit him up
and he can help you get on your way so
yes everybody I will see you all next
time funny fat bit this is how we do it
this is how we do it less sub smack
abilities mega boo what listen unless
the germaphobic bacteria feet feet what
the [ __ ] you do I am NOT being gymnast
or that seriously